hallo liebe leute willkommen zurück bei
einer neuen episode the german aus
berlin heute ist bei uns oder olga wo
kommst du her
ich bin aus russland ich vorne ihm
bleiben
das ist eine stadt in russland alge hat
uns geschrieben so könnt ihr das auch
mal machen einfach eine e-mail
geschrieben ich bin in berlin kann ich
mit euch ein video drehen
und hier ist eure heute fragen wir etwas
zum thema familie
da könnt ihr mal ein bisschen euren
einfachen wortschatz üben wie sieht eine
familie in deutschland aus welchem
familienmitglieder gehören dazu
wo sind die familienmitglieder das wird
eurer jetzt auf der straße herausfinden
hier ist ein mikrofon neuer
was bedeutet die familie für die familie
ist extrem wichtig und vor allen dingen
ist die familie mein zuhause und damit
ist eigentlich alles gesagt
die familie ist das zentrum unseres
lebens aus der kontrolle auf unser film
konzentriert sich alles die lieb uns
kraft von beruf wie nachhausekommen
vergisst man das alles das sehen wir
gerade wenn wir zu unseren enkel haben
wir werden unser enkel tag in der woche
haben wir den enkel tag das ist ein
höhepunkt in unserem leben das ist
familie und sehr sehr wichtig eigentlich
alles also hilft mir bei allen schule
arbeit und ohne familie eigentlich
nichts was bedeutet die familie für sie
sehr viel fast alles
familien fuß
ich habe keine aktuelle familie ich
komme aus einer familie deswegen ist
meine herkunft
das hat mich geprägt und ich bin
wahrscheinlich zu größtes wege so wie
ich bin
welche aus dieser familie komme was
bedeutet die familie die sie eine ganze
menge zusammenhalt rückzugsort ja
letztendlich auch geborgenheit familie
ist sehr viel vor allen dingen sollte
man sie nicht vergessen die familie
bedeutet für mich zusammenhalt und sorge
um einander ja bedeutet die familie neue
neue familienmitglieder auch viele
aufgaben aber auch viel freude aber auch
viel ärger also eigentlich von allem
mehr von allem was man feuer hatte mehr
außer zeit davon weniger
die familie ist das zuhause des wenn man
sich geborgen fühlt und gerne auch mal
gern streit hat oder die familie
bedeutet mir persönlich alles und sie
ist ein sehr großer teil meines lebens
und ein sehr wichtiger teil in meinen ja
als rückhalt für mich und in der
unterstützung und sie ist überall in
deutschland verteilt und bedeutet für
mich sehr viel liebe familie ist
grundsätzlich sehr wichtig ich habe
selber eine eigene familie der tochter
und auch meine eltern und die großeltern
sind schon von ein wichtiger bestandteil
im leben sagt ich mache alles eigentlich
ja kann man also nicht eigentlich alles
familie ist superwichtig
das einzige was man hat wenn man wenn
man nichts mehr hat dann kann man immer
oder sollte man einmal die familie haben
um sich herum welche mitglieder haben
sie ich habe zwei söhne und meine eltern
und meine zwei brüder das ist so meine
meine familie haben sie eine große
familie
wir haben gut geschwister jahr hat jeder
von uns ich habe noch drei geschwister
mein mann hat noch zwei geschichten am
main mutter am ende
meine eltern sind getrennt aber und
meinen großen bruder halt ich habe eine
tochter und eine stieftochter und eine
frau welche familienmitglieder hast du
es habe zwei brüder und eine schwester
heute ist unsere frage zum thema familie
welche familienmitglieder hast du gar
kein ich bin alleine alleine eine lüge
wie immer aber sie kämen genau so viel
habe ich habe eine frau zwei kinder und
drei geliebte ich habe eine freundin und
meine familie natürlich von meiner
mutter und meinem vater ja ich habe
einen sohn
eine mutter eine schwester und zwei
nichten und natürlich ein onkel und eine
tante einen vater eine mutter zwei
kinder und dann habe ich halt selber
noch eltern und verwandte ja nicht so
groß aber ich hab ne zwillingsschwester
meine eltern oma opa also ganz normal
mich heißt deine zwillingsschwester das
ja unter du sauer ich habe zwei
geschwister und ich habe meine eltern
beide und ich habe noch alle vier
großeltern und meine eltern haben auch
sehr viele geschwister die haben kinder
also wir sind wir sind eine große
familie
ich habe eine kleine tochter wie gesagt
meine familie ist also recht klein sag
ich mal meine eltern wohnen in der nähe
von berlin und bei denen es häufig am
wochenende ja ist ja mal relativ aber
mein vater ist italiener und da hat man
ja automatisch mehr im süden angesiedelt
immer ein bisschen die größeren familien
genau aber meine mutter hat auch drei
schwestern und somit dann auch wieder
kinder also ja und auch erkennen sie mir
erzählen eine familiengeschichte oder
eine familie dort in eine besondere
sache in meiner familie ist weihnachten
und weihnachten hat bei uns sehr viele
traditionen wir haben sehr viele sachen
die wir immer jedes jahr so machen
vierten advent fahren wir zusammen in
den wald und holen einen weihnachtsbaum
am 23 wird ja zusammen aufgestellt dann
wird das zimmer verschlossen und am 24
gehen wir erst zusammen in die kirche zu
fuß wieder nach hause und zählen die
weihnachtsbäume in denen die kerzen
schon brennen und dann gibt es eine
kleine glocke wenn wir ins zimmer gehen
dürfen und dann gibt es sehr viel musik
und singen und essen und plätzchen und
so das ist sehr speziell für meine
familie und da darf auch nicht viel
neues passieren also es muss jedes jahr
immer wieder genauso sein
schwer also ich könnte das ist sich
immer ganz stolz auf meine großeltern
die waren über 50 jahre verheiratet und
haben uns auch ganz groß gefeiert und
erst auf der feier haben sie erzählt
dass sie eigentlich nur geheiratet habe
meine oma schwanger und vorher nicht und
ist ja ja wir dachten alles war aus
liebe
doch deshalb eine familiengeschichte
hier zählen die marlene das ist die
marlene jaschke zweitname rebecca man
meine zwillingsschwester heißt rebecca
eine sehr kleine familiengeschichte und
zwar war ich glaube ich 18 oder so und
zwar wochenende und ich habe geschlafen
und ich hatte mal das kippen ausprobiert
und hatte so ein bisschen noch in der
tasche in der handtasche und der
postbote hat eine haustür geklingelt und
mein vater brauchte bargeld weil ein
paket ablösen musste und den postboten
bezahlen musste und dann hat er in meine
tasche geschaut weil er kein bares mehr
zu hause hatte und hat beim schauen in
meinem portemonnaie gras gefunden und
dann kann er anschließend in mein zimmer
und er hat uns ein bisschen
italienischen akzent und hat dann wie
gesagt ich war noch am schlafen kam in
mein zimmer geplatzt und hat einfach
gesagt signori na was machst du mit der
schnitt in der tasche
aber ich habe zum beispiel gestern abend
habe ich meine kinder ins bett gebracht
und habe ihnen eine gute nacht
geschichte vorgelesen und da habe ich
wieder da habe ich mal wieder so richtig
gefühlt was es heißt kinder zu haben und
mit ihnen zu kommunizieren und ihnen
auch einen schönen abend zu bereiten
ich hatte es nur weil der klub für sehr
kleine geboren wurde
da saßen wir beide mehr s bahn und habe
vor schreck verpasst auszusteigen weil
wir uns die nachricht mitten über über
plattencover stadt dass wir auch einmal
in der s-bahn oma und opa geworden sind
also das war wirklich selber dass es
gibt die anekdote in meiner geschichte
dass mein großvater väterlicherseits
seine ganzen kinder so verheiratet hat
dass sie ein haus bekommen das war
natürlich damals in den
sechziger jahren sehr wichtig
das war sehr bunte schon ganz gut
funktioniert ja geantwortet ja ich habe
viele interessante geschichte gehört
die leute leben ihr ihre familien
das war wunderbar das ist schön
wahrscheinlich überall auf der welt oder
dann liebe zuschauer das war's für heute
danke dass du uns versucht solga wenn
ihr auch mal uns treffen möchtest dann
kommt entweder nach berlin oder trifft
uns unterwegs wir ist fahren wir zum
beispiel demnächst in die usa im oktober
dafür sammeln wir noch geld wir besuchen
dort schulen universitäten und leute die
privat deutsch lernen und vielleicht
können wir auch euch treffen hier unten
findet ihr noch mal den link zu unserer
indigo kampagne die noch bis anfang
oktober läuft wir freuen uns auf eure
unterstützung wenn wir uns etwas
zurückgeben möchte ansonsten abonniert
unseren kanal und wir sehen uns nächste
woche wieder bringen sie darin